breaking now from raider nation head
coach john gruden under fire today for
comments he made in an email back in
2011. good afternoon thanks so much for
joining us at four i'm kirsten joyce and
i'm christian casadas let's head right
over to ron fertrell he's following all
the developments and he joins us live in
studio for us ron what's the update yeah
the email was from 10 years ago when
gruden was working for espn he was
writing to an executive with the
washington football team and he was
complaining about demarcus smith who was
black and who was head of the nfl
players association at the time and
gruden said quote
dumboris smith has lips the size of
michelin tires
end quote gruden told the wall street
journal quote i was upset i used a
horrible way of explaining it i don't
think he's dumb i don't think he's a
liar i don't have a racial bone in my
body and i've proven that for 58 years
in quote now the nfl also issued a
statement today they said the email from
john gruden
denigrating to morris smith is appalling
abhorrent and holy contrary to the nfl's
values we condemn the statement and
regret any harm that its publications
may inflict on mr smith or anyone else
end quote now i spoke with frank hawkins
this afternoon he is a former head of
the naacp here in the valley and of
course a former raiders running back he
had harsh words for gruden the raiders
and the nfl
a lot of us believe that
that kind of discussion goes on in the
nfl all the time so if nobody has a
comment
then that's typical status quo that they
protect their own
simple when you say you're not surprised
you're not surprised if gruden would say
that or not surprised that it would just
be a statement from an nfl coach
i'm not surprised number one that gruden
said it and number two i'm not surprised
that no one including the nfl wants to
talk about it the next question is
what's mark davis going to do about
gruden what should we tell what should
happen to john gruden with this and with
the raiders
i'm not the owner but if i could if i
was the owner we wouldn't have that
discussion because he wouldn't be the
coach
there you go gruden met with the raiders
players this morning letting them know
the story and apologizing for it and
letting them know the story was going to
come out now this is all part of of a
purging by the nfl where they are going
through 650 000 emails looking for
whatever they can find the raiders
released a statement a short time ago
that says that quote the email quote is
disturbing and not what the raiders
stand for we were first made aware of
the email late yesterday by a reporter
and are reviewing it along with other
materials provided to us today by the
nfl we are addressing the matter with
coach gruden and we'll have no further
comment at this time that statement from
mark davis there the wall street journal
did not say how they got the e-mail but
nobody has denied that it is indeed
authentic will of course continue to
follow this story